Grandmaster Maurice Ashley with a
special guest from Paris Ave Philippe
yes indeed the CFO with Wendy is every
Philippe welcome to our show how excited
are you to see this event finally taking
place here at the studio well we are
excited this is a great event and we
like to have it here in our main offices
here in Paris so we are very very proud
- two of them today to play in our
offices so you've been a fine sponsor
for quite a while now
why chess watch as why is it so
important for you well we sponsor for
four or five years now so this is
important for us chess is a very
interesting games cause the worldwide
game you know so everybody everywhere in
the world you can play chess you see
people playing chess every even it's
very small countries or very far country
so we are an international group in fact
even we are based in Paris with an
international group so we like to ask
such sorts of games which can be played
all over the world you know you ventured
also outside of Europe and sponsored the
Abidjan events as what has taken why why
dadly because we have special focus on
Africa I would say we have a big show
although with Balu a group who is well
which is very well deployed I would say
in Africa especially in ports this being
said we intend to develop content and
video on music in Africa which are main
businesses and we believe that Africa is
a very big continent which will develop
in the coming years on decades I know so
it's very important for the group like
we Verdi to invest now in Africa to
benefit all these growth in the coming
years for the future you guys sound like
chess players with the big visions you
mentioned that the another big event
that's going to be taking place here
tomorrow you mentioned in your opening
statements about the Tour de France that
seems incredible and that's going to be
concluding just a few steps from here
while we're doing this event well this
is
even the Tour de France you know but
this is an interesting even - I would
say very different from the gone chess -
which is more intellectual I would say
but let's say the total force is also
something interesting because this is
the most important free event and why is
it free it's because it's been financed
by advertising and Viva do we have a big
subsidy which is specialized in
advertising which is called Ava's that's
why I made this parallel between the
Tour de France and from the contest oh I
see now as far as the chest is concerned
do you have a favorite player you think
is going to win or you'd like to see me
while I know I think that they are all
very very good players last year ago we
made some poor arms plays last year and
I played at that time with Maxime about
obviously I was not as good as the other
player so we lost at the first the first
page I think you would have said I want
maxy maxy maxy hard to say that last
year I played with it because we have to
what a matter and when when professional
and we lost this was my fault indeed but
so I wish the aim very good luck and
hope we will win I'm sure he's forgiving
you for for a long time thank you very
much very much thank you Ave Philippe of
Vivendi the CFO there very visionary of
course as sponsors and that's what we
need in chess